G: Okay, let's see. T: *whispers* Okay, let's see. G: No, it's not a mirroring exercise.
G: Hi guys, I'm here with my mom! T: Hey!
G: Mom has been on my Youtube channel so many times, and she's out
here visiting for Thanksgiving, so I thought i would exploit her one more time. T: Yay! G: If not two or three more times before she leaves, and
make a video with her. I went on Twitter to ask you guys for
ideas for videos that we could shoot together and someone said "Even though it's a classic or an old kind of challenge: the Whisper
Challenge might be fun to do." And I love the whisper, challenge and you don't know
what it is. T: I do not know anything. Does it have to do with speaking softly?
G: Yes. In this challenge, basically
one of the two people involved puts on some noise cancelling headphones- these are a not noise canceling, but
we can just crank them really loud- then the other person
tries to say a phrase to the person wearing the headphones but now
you try, and guess what the person's saying. T: Okay. G: I thought because my
mom is such a lovely positive sweet person that instead of just randomly picking phrases, I found really
short inspirational quotes of of Pinterest- T: Perfect.
G: that we can choose to say. T: Sounds great. G: And there's no real winners or losers in this challenge,
we'll just play until we're tired. T: No, everyone wins.
G: That's not how the internet works.
G: Look how positive she is!
G: Would you like to guess first or read quotes first? T: Guess first. G: You want to guess first? T: Yes. G: Okay.
T: Yes, I'm your guest, so I want to guess. G: What do you want to listen to? T: I'd have some relaxing classical music, right?
G: No, we're gonna put Taylor Swift's new album on for you. T: I love Taylor Swift, she's good and sweet. Whoa! G: Can you hear me? T: That is loud.
T: I can't hear you, though.
G: Okay, you can also put your hands over-
G: Oh oh. First one!
T: What? G: Okay. T: What? I can't hear you, Grace.
G; Perfectly imperfect.
T: One more time. G: Perfectly imperfect. T: Life is perfect. G: Perfectly imperfect. T: You're so perfect. G: Perfectly imperfect. T: Is
perfect part of it? Perfect has something to do with it.
G: Perfectly imperfect.
T: Porcupine the perfect.
T: Porcupine are pointy.
G: Perfectly- T: Perfectly pointy.
G: Pe- T: What? I can't hear!
T: Why can't you speak up?
T: I can't hear anything you say. G: Perfectly imperfect.
T: *mouths* Porcupine.
G: It was 'Perfectly Imperfect'.
T: Oh... That- It didn't have anything to do with porcupine.
T: Okay, don't look. How do I scroll through?
G: It's not an Ipad. Did you jus- My mom's just swiping my laptop. T: Oh my god. There's so many good ones. So many good ones.
T: Oh. I deleted it?
G: This part should not take this long. T: Okay. Real queens- G: Thirty Williams. T: I'm not finished. Real queens-
G: Real witches love baths. T: Real qu-
T: Real queens fix each other's crowns. G: Fruity-
Judy from Family Matters. T: Time-out. Read my lips. Real queens fix
each other's crowns. G: Real queens like garbage.
T: Real queens fix each other's crowns.
G: Real queens fix troaths.
G: Real queens eat garbage.
*laughter*
G: Trash. T: Crowns. Crowns. Crowns.
G: Grass. T: Crowns. G: Grass. T: Crowns.
*various Crowns and Grass'es*
G: Real queens fix each other's ass.
G: Real queens cover each other's trash.
G: Real queens cover each other's tracks. Hide in secret. T: Crowns.
T: Crowns. G: Hats. T: Crowns. Real queens fix each other's crowns.
G: Real queens fix each other's crowns? T: Yes!
T: Yes, we did it! Woo-hoo!
G: Oh my god.
G: Ready? Create your own sunshine.
T: Again. G: Create your own sunshine. T: Grapes grow on the vine.
T: They do, they do. G: That's true.
G: Create your own sunshine.
T: Grapes make good wine.
T: They do, they do. G: Create-
T: Grace. G: No, no. Create-
your own- T: Grace is my daughter.
T: That should be one. G: Okay. Create your own sunshine. T: Great trolls of the show.
G: Create your own sunshine.
T: Gray trolls have no money. G: This one is: create your own sunshine. T: Oh-
T: That's better?
G: Don't just exist, live.
T: Somebody enlisted in the navy. G: Don't just exist, live.
T: Okay, we'll have gravy on Thanksgiving.
G: Don't- T: Is it gravy or navy at the end? G: Don't just live- live.
T: You have a really nice smile.
G; *laughs* You can't do that!
G: It was don- T: You said I can't say nothing, so I had-
to say something. T: Aspire to inspire-
before we- G: Baffoons? T: -expire. G: A spatula.
T: Aspire to inspire before- G: Spatulas have two uses. T: -we expire. G: To make pans.
T: Inspire before we expire. G: Julia Av- is the best?
T: Aspire to inspire before we expire. G: Myers-Briggs tells you about class. T: Aspire to inspire- G: Hunchback. T: -before we expire.
G: Hunchbacks afore munchbacks. T: Aspire to in- G: Sketchers... T: -inspire before we expire. G: Before- This is a long one. T: This is a long one.
G: It's a long one, it's very-
T: Enjoy the little things.
G: Julie likes certain things. T: Enjoy the little things. G: Jewish loves other things. T: Enjoy the little things.
Enjoy the little things.
G: It's true I love other things. T: Enjoy the little things. G: It's true I love the Lion King. T: Enj- that's getting close- enjoy-
the little things. G: Sssh- should we-
G: Why don't we just come up with our own sentences for each other, like short little things. T: Okay.
G: That make sense for us. T: Okay. G: Okay? I'm your favorite child.
G: I'm-
your favorite child. T: You're so happy.
T: Open? G: I'm your favorite child. T: Your favorite show. G: I'm your favorite child. T: Is that your favorite show?
T: No? G: I'm your favorite child. T: You're my favorite daughter. Yeah. You're my favorite child.
G: Uh- Yeah, yeah. She said it, Tim. Eat sh*t.
G: Eat shit! T: Do good and be good. G: You're a big girl. T: Do good and be good. G: You look like
me a little. T: Do good and be good. G: You like big things. T: Do good and be good. G: You love
me. T: Do- I do. Do good and be good. G: You have a-
G: You've been raised great. T: Do good- G: You could- T: And be good. G: Beer...
G: You said beer. T: Do good and be good. G: You could- you could be great. T: Then you can have a beer. Do good. G: You can't be good.
*laugher*
T: *low voice* Do good and be good. G: Work on being better.
T: Do good and be good. I was saying that to you. G: Oh.
G: We- Why was I gonna know that?
G: That literally could have been pulled right of Pinterest just now.
T: I was saying that to you. G: I made it specific.
G: It was really fun. T: It was fun. G: I think our
abs have been totally worked out. Thank you mom for participating. T: You're so welcome.
G: I think i'm gonna shoot another video with my mom before she leaves, so leave a comment down below
letting me know what other video
we should shoot. Thank you guys for watching, subscribe to this Youtube channel if you haven't already. Other than that, I don't know.
T: That was great. G: Ha... T: One more thing.
G: Oh my god. T: I love you and I'm so glad to be here.